how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we have a ridiculously awesome one
division plot leaked a plot league that
involves the one and only Ultron and the
really cool thing about this plot leak
is it was posted before Disney Plus came
out and before we could see Marvel
Studios says expanding the universe
video but a lot in the plot leaked has
been confirmed in the expanding the
universe video so this plot leaked could
be very legitimate which means there is
a very legitimate chance that Ultron
could be returning to the MCU in the one
division series so I'll go ahead and
break down this plot leak in this video
actually to plot leaks about the one
division series and I'll also talk about
everything expanding the universe said
about one a vision as well I'm still
doing my xbox one and ps4 giveaway all
you have to do to enter is subscribe
with the notifications turned on like
this video and comment down below so
again like I said some of this plot
leaked has already been proven true and
this plot leaked is said to come from
somebody who is working directly on the
film it starts off by stating that after
the events of Avengers endgame Wanda is
depressed and homeless a mysterious
woman named Agatha comes across Wanda
and offers her a deal Agatha can make a
pocket dimension of the perfect world
for Wanda as long as she stays there
forever
Wanda agrees Wanda's perfect world
consists of vision with her two newborn
babies wicken and speed Agatha appears
as a nosy neighbor to keep an eye out on
Wanda as she plans to kill her after the
two babies grow up which they do in the
span of a week in the main MCU dimension
on earth FBI agent Jimmy woo with his
recruits Darcy Lewis and Monica Rambeau
are hired to solve a case regarding
Agatha leading them to where they get
sucked into Wanda's pocket dimension
guest stars and cameos include lisanna
Lynch as an elderly Maria using CGI
James Spader as Ultron with archived
footage from age of Ultron and Benedict
Cumberbatch as Doctor Strange the final
episode of the series will lead into
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness Dick Van Dyke and Carol Burnett
were offered cameo roles of an elderly
couple and Wanda's perfect world Ben
Barnes and Dominic West are cast as
scythe on and the Grim Reaper Agatha's
two minions who are tasked to kill
vision and the babies so this is the
first plot leak that we have and it
makes a lot of sense it makes a lot of
sense that Wanda is going to be
depressed
after the events of Avengers in game in
infinity war she lost vision and not to
mention she died in infinity war as well
but almost everyone got brought back to
life in Avengers in game but vision
didn't and also her brother Quicksilver
didn't as well as far as how she becomes
homeless that's probably somewhat of a
personal choice she probably runs away
from everything because the rest of the
remaining Avengers would not let her be
homeless
especially Hawkeye but Wanda becoming
unstable is something that happens kind
of frequently in the comics so this
makes sense that she would kind of go
off on her owned and slowly start to
lose her mind
now Agatha Harkness and the comics
actually is not evil she's a witch but
she becomes the magical tutor for the
Scarlet Witch punka dimensions are
something that occur in the comics with
Agatha Harkness
and at one point in time Agatha does
wipe the memory of Wanda's children from
her brain now this does seem a little
bit evil but it is after they died in
Wanda is slowly starting to lose her
mind
but eventually she does find out about
her kids and she does confront Agatha so
this is a little bit of a twist making
her evil making her create the pocket
dimension and her wanting to kill Wanda
but the pocket dimension makes sense
because we were kind of wondering how
exactly vision is going to come back to
life and how exactly they're going to go
back to the 50s or why they're going to
go back to the 50s but if Agatha creates
a perfect world for Wanda and that world
is in the 50s well that's how they get
there in this pocket dimension not to
mention this is probably how they have
kids as well because they probably can't
have kids and in fact in the comics the
way Wanda gets pregnant is she ends up
absorbing energy which makes her
pregnant now as far as Agatha is
concerned she's going to be played by
Kathryn ha and this actually ended up
being confirmed after this plot leak
came out on Disney Plus Marvel released
they're expanding the universe video and
in this video they talked a lot about
the Disney Plus Marvel shows that are
coming very soon and during this video
they introduced Katherine Hong as the
nosy neighbor of Wanda and vision not to
mention they did also confirm Jimmy woo
Darcy Lewis and Monica Rambeau when they
introduced randall park kat dennings and
tiana paris as well so a good majority
of this plot leaked has already been
confirmed after the plot leaked came out
which makes us believe that this could
be very legitimate which makes the next
part even more exciting the return of
Ultron now they do state that some
is going to be archived footage but of
course it is also possible that a katha
could bring Ultron back Ultron is
considered one of the greatest Marvel
villains of all time and a lot of people
were pretty ticked off with age of
Ultron how they portrayed him and the
fact that they killed him he's such a
huge villain to just kill off in one
movie but it looks like we could be seen
a little bit more of him in the 1
division series and of course this will
all lead up to Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness which has been
confirmed and Wanda will indeed be in
the movie as well now it hasn't been
confirmed that vision is going to be in
the movie which leads us to believe that
maybe this all does exist in a pocket
dimension and it may be Doctor Strange
ends up pulling her out and maybe that's
why vision is not going to be in the
Doctor Strange movie now as I mentioned
we do have another plot leak that came
out for this series the very same day as
this other one this pot leak comes from
Charles Murphy of Murphy's Law podcast
and he has been right about many leaks
in the past and his plot leaked actually
lines up with the previous one to start
off with Charles says that the very
beginning episodes of the one division
series are going to be filmed in front
of a live audience
this is to pay homage to the
long-running sitcom I Love Lucy which
was the first sitcom to be filmed in
front of a live audience for a scripted
show he says that the first episodes are
going to be filmed in front of a live
audience because they are set in the
past but as we move forward in the
episodes we're going to see one to
envision go forward in time now perhaps
this is because they somehow get out of
the pocket dimension or maybe the pocket
dimension changes but he does go on to
say that Wanda envisioned our playing at
being the ideal nuclear family for much
of the early part of the series we won't
be seen the synthezoid version of vision
he will look an awful lot like we saw
him in Avengers infinity war and be
holding down a job as he and Wanda build
their life in the suburbs and he says of
course the perfect nuclear family means
doing all those perfect family things
like having kids hosting parties and
hanging out with your neighbors
dot dot dot more on the neighbor in a
second but this perfect family doesn't
really seem possible in real life after
all as I mentioned vision is dead and
even if he was alive they probably
couldn't have kids together but that
points us back to Agatha creating this
perfect world for Wanda in this pocket
dimension now remember
Gotha is supposed to be in this pocket
dimension as well supposedly being the
neighbor now Marvel has not officially
revealed who Catherine Hans character is
they simply said she's going to be
playing their nosy neighbor but Charles
Murphy says that Kathryn Hahn is going
to be playing a character named Agnes he
does state that he doesn't really know
who Agnes is but it is a very similar
name to Agatha now if Agatha the witch
is going to create a pocket dimension
for the Scarlet Witch she's clearly
going to know who Agatha is so perhaps
she disguises herself since she plans on
killing Wanda as this person named Agnes
and these two plot leaks line up with
each other pretty well but then Disney
Plus launched and with it came expanding
the universe and did this we got to hear
from the writers the producers and the
directors of the Disney Plus shows and
of course they talked about Wanda and
vision and what they said and what they
revealed line up with these plot leaks
as well the director of the series said
that this show is going to be like
something that Marvel fans have never
seen before she said it's going to be
half classic sitcom and half full MCU
spectacular but then Mary Livanos who is
a supervising producer for the series
came in and said so much of the fun and
watching this show for the fans is going
to be the unexpected discovery of where
and when this show takes place in the
MCU now where and when kind of sound
like a pocket dimension because they
already say win because that's the 50s
we already know that but she also said
we're if there wasn't some type of
alternate reality or pocket dimension
when somebody would ask where is the one
division series going to take place you
would say somewhere in the suburbs in
the 1950s but they made it a point to
stress when and where which seems to be
a bit more of a confirmation that this
is going to involve a pocket dimension
and then not to mention that several
people in expanding the universe
elizabeth Olsen herself say that this
show is going to get weird it's going to
be weird but then it's going to grow
into this big spectacular thing and if
these plot leaks end up being true then
yes it is going to be weird Wanda and
vision are going to have kids they're
going to grow up within a week and this
was also kind of hinted at and confirmed
in the expanding the universe video as
well Paul Bettany who of course plays
vision says that the show is
funny and it ends up being this huge
epic
and as he says that they show on the
screen a copy of the number four issue
of the vision and the Scarlet Witch and
on the cover of that issue it says the
vision and the Scarlet Witch are having
a baby but dot dot there's really no
other reason why they would show this
particular cover unless they are indeed
having kids it's a twelve book limited
comic book series they could have shown
eleven other covers all of them not
having anything to do with them having a
baby but the fact that they did show
this particular issue with this
particular cover saying that they're
having a baby does really hint that and
probably confirms that they are going to
have Wiccan and speed in this series and
then as I mentioned before they ended
the one division section of expanding
the universe by introducing three new
members of the cast and as I mentioned
these were Randall Park who is playing
Jimmy woo kat dennings who is playing
Darcy Lewis and Tiana Paris who is
playing an adult version of Monica
Rambeau
so like I said there's a good chance
that these plot leaks could be very
legitimate and if they do end up being
true then this series is going to be
absolutely incredible
I love the twist on Agatha Harkness I
like how they kind of stay true to the
comics with Wanda kind of being unstable
I like the fact that Wiccan and speed
are going to be in the Wanda vision
series and I like the fact that it's
going to lead into Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and of course I
love the fact that they could be
throwing in Ultron and hopefully it'll
be more than just archived footage of
him hopefully they bring him back in
some way even if it's just for the
series but let me know what you think
about this if these pot leaks end up
being true would you be happy with the
way that the Wanda vision series is
going to go be sure to let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below if
you enjoyed the video give it a thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe with
the notifications turned on so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 I'll be picking a new
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof